so
If he if he's paid his money he's paid
we believe you know around about five
million quid why is that not the end of
it
I think the minimum the British public
expect from any politician but certainly
someone who's been the chancellor of the
exchequer is that they would have paid
all their taxes without having to be
prompted to do so or harassed or
campaigned against to do so and the
position to me is completely untenable
and I think the prime minister's got to
act and we'll see that very quickly
today why because people quite rightly
want all of their politicians to abide
by the rules they want anyone in public
life to not see paying taxes somehow an
optional thing that if you're caught out
you have to go back and do they want
that property up front that
accountability that professionalism that
integrity and that hasn't been the case
here I don't think the excuses are
compelling or clearly a great many
people have received lawyers letters
when they've even queried with the right
amount of tax has been paid and the sums
of money here are not small I mean if
the if the reports are true the amount
of income that hasn't been declared
would be very very large indeed and I
just don't think in any way it's tenable
to continue in a high profile position
in public life when you've not behaved
in that way but if it's a genuine
mistake and as soon as you have been
made aware by hmrc that it was that you
know you they have accepted that it was
a mistake that he didn't do it on
purpose and he's immediately paid the
amount of money that's owing plus a 30
penalty as well we believe
um what else can you do well the two
things I would immediately say are first
of all if that settlement were reached
whilst that person were Chancellor of
the exchequeror in charge of hm Mossy
that would be surely an enormous
conflict of interest and that's why they
would have to be the the publication of
Correspondence and transparency in that
area as well but also how would that
explanation tally against settling
sending threatening letters to people
who did query whether the tax Affairs
were correct Julie if you made an honest
mistake and somebody pointed it out you
would look at it and then correct that
mistake rather than ask them to stop
speaking publicly about the mistake that
you've made
um he was Chancellor We Believe at the
time that he made this uh payment but
um he wouldn't necessarily have known
that he was being investigated well
I don't think in this position based on
what we do know it's possible for that
person in this case Madame zahari to
claim ignorance and claim that there's
nothing he could have done about that I
mean this is a this is a set of
circumstances which I would say are
completely untenable with remaining with
a senior position in public life and the
Prime Minister has to take action to
grow mad Mr Sahari says um that the hmrc
have accepted at least in part that
these shares were in for his father and
his balshaw um offshore company in
Gibraltar and they have accepted that
but they were disputing the number of
shares he says that if he hadn't had a
senior position in government then he
would have been contesting that but
because he has had a senior positioning
government at the time he felt that his
job was to settle it quickly and then he
could get on with his very important job
will the kind of arrangement that's
being talked about I would say is an
unusual arrangement in terms of
financing a company or a new Venture I'm
afraid I'm just not convinced and the
danger is that the public see a case
like this and let's be honest this is
not the first sleazy or or questionable
bit of activity from this government and
I just think all politics and public
life revolves in this way and it doesn't
and it undermines the property of the
country and it undermines the confidence
people have in the political system so
I'm afraid I'm not willing to accept
those kind of explanations I don't think
what we already know can be tallied with
maintaining that senior position in
public life but the tax lawyer who says
that he's discovered these discrepancies
Mr needle says that he can only see
about 99
000 pounds so um if if he's got this
fantastic legal um tax legal mind and he
could only find that much how should we
expect somebody like Nadim zahawi who's
very busy running the finances of the
country to know any more than that well
I think first of all we should thank
campaigners for tax transparency and
openness because by we as a labor party
member well I think it is fair to say if
you look at the transparency in the
light that Daniel has shown on these
Affairs and the threats that he received
in exchange for that I don't think his
politics his personal choices are
irrelevant to that I think he's done the
country of service I think we should all
want to live in a country where there is
that kind of transparency and scrutiny
of our politicians but very clearly this
is not a standard set of of Arrangements
in terms of the tax Affairs of the
chairman of the conservative party
clearly there are questions to answer
transparency would have helped that but
I see no indication that we would have
got this had it not been for those
campaigners looking into this and
Publishing what they had found I've said
member I don't know if he's a labor
party member labor party supporter do
you
um I I don't know okay what about the
chairman of the BBC what should happen
to him well I cleanly's investigating
and again here we are talking about
behavior in public life which is not how
this country should operate I I'm fed up
having to come and talk about this even
though it's the conservative party who
are always at the heart oh wait we
should be talking about the cost of
living crisis or how we should be making
the most of the exciting new
opportunities that could be available to
the country but again time and time
again we've got to talk about this
because it is newsworthy it is important
to cover it but it's not how things
should be in this country and I I there
seems no end to be honest under this
government it feels very much like the
end of the last conservative government
compared to the the 1990s when they fell
from power at that point and I'm I'm
frustrated by it to be honest but
clearly there are huge questions of a
conflict of interest here between
someone being involved in arranging a
substantial amount of money for the then
prime minister and then receiving one of
the highest appointments in public life
again that it's possible to get on that
BBC chair um Richard Sharp does he not
have um questions to answer yes I mean
clearly I mean the fact that people
think it might be okay I want to know
when he first had conversations about
this role when and how that related to
the other request to arrange a
substantial sum of money for the then
prime minister I would want to know the
relationship between those two things
but I also want to know how the
conservative party themselves think this
looks okay imagine it's all above board
much we find that out
do they not see that this looks
inappropriate as a way to behave as a
government and I think frankly they've
just been in power for too long they
have forgotten to put them into power
and the responsibility and faith that
was placed in them and until they have
the shock of having that power taken
away from them they'll not be willing to
look seriously at their own behavior and
how they continually get into these
scandals is it not reasonable for the
pride the then prime minister Boris
Johnson going back a few but the then
prime minister Boris Johnson
um to um have a dinner uh away from the
public Spotlight with somebody who could
be chairman of the BBC he needed to
check him out and also a cousin of his
at Checkers what's wrong with that
I don't think the dining Arrangements of
the former prime minister are the
question here I think it always comes
down to the fact that there are
continually these enormous conflicts of
interest whether it's the the Scandal
around procuring PPE in the pandemic or
the tax Affairs of senior conservative
members of the cabinet or situations
like this where people have received
very significant appointments or other
roles that are you know incredibly
important in how this country operates
and it comes back to their core
credential being not just political
support for the conservative party but
often personal financial Arrangements
that are intertwined with senior
conservatives I don't think the public
thinks that as in any way acceptable I
want to know why senior conservatives
continued to think that is an acceptable
way to behave we were talking just
before we came on air about how cold it
is um today the National Grid
um is saying that they're trying to put
things in place to try and stop
blackouts so you shouldn't use as much
energy at tea time tonight and that's
easy said than done isn't it well it is
and I think whilst advice about how you
know the weather conditions have affect
energy consumption well all of that
should be part of an educated and
involved Energy System but the bottom
line is this we have enormous resources
in this country we can finally get to a
position where we can combine low carbon
energy with energy security and a low
competitive price because of how the
relative price of fossil fuels has risen
the message from government not just
regulates the message from government
should be how we make the most of that
how we maximize the opportunities of
that and it shouldn't be a message that
people think oh is this about rationing
my own use because of course we should
all use energy efficiently but the story
there should be about the massive
opportunities available to the country
which right now this government are
completely not seizing we're being
completely outgunned by what's happening
with the Biden Administration in the US
and how that European Union will then
respond to that we are missing out on
these opportunities there is no problems
to deal with it well exactly this prime
minister is dealing with internal
conservative party problems when
actually what we need is a government
focused on the big opportunities of the
future problems as well um given that
we're in the middle of a customer living
crisis is it right that we have a
three-day Extravaganza for the
coronation
well I think if you're going to have
hereditary monarchy you're probably
going to make a big deal of coronations
I'm not aware of the plans I'm not aware
of the scale of it I would usually
expect it to be done in a in a certain
way so look I to be honest haven't
looked at that don't have a particularly
strong view on that but I would always
expect a coronation to be a fairly
significant event in the Swedish history
I honestly don't know where that's the
standard procedure because it's so long
since we've had one or whether this is a
new proposal put forward but look I
think
uh one thing you would absolutely say
about
um the the tragic passing of a late
Majesty Queen Elizabeth it was it wasn't
where the country came together I didn't
actually quite like that even though you
know I wouldn't say necessarily this
this would be my default as to how the
head of state should be should be um
organized but look it brought the
country together and I I you know I
think that was quite an important moment
if a coronation can do the same that
would be nice